hey everybody and welcome to a striking
wild ride with stevo coming at you from
a sold out stop on stevo's bucket list
tour and this week we've got the
exciting the brimming with confidence
suga sean o'malley the self-proclaimed
unranked champion of the ufc and i gotta
say i love this kid i love his
confidence and i love the conversation
that we had on our ridiculously
luxurious tour bus this one's great and
like i said i got a big show tonight and
i'm gonna get ready for it right now
which means i can't have this scrub on
my face
not when i'm prepared to give myself the
best shave i can possibly get with my
harry's razor
i'm telling you if you're not using
these you're not getting as good a shave
as you can that's my opinion plus it's
so reasonably priced man i am faithful
to this brand for
well over a year before i was introduced
to them professionally and if you go to
harrys.com stevo you're going to get a
great deal for a limited time on a
holiday season shave kit which comes
with a weighted ergonomic handle you're
going to have three razor cartridges the
travel case which makes it safe in your
toiletry kit plus foaming shave gel
you're gonna get five dollars off that
order and free shipping and again it's
the best shave you can get so go to
harrys.com
stevo to get this amazing deal and hurry
up because there's a guy in your life
who's tough to shop for who's gonna
really appreciate this shave kit so get
that for him for christmas
now while i get ready for this show
let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen suga's sean
o'malley
the sugar show
yeah dude good to see you brother i feel
like we're on [ __ ] tour i mean you're
like rock stars they're sitting in this
in this boss this is [ __ ] sweet it's
1.7 million dollar podcast we got going
on right here i think that this tour bus
is valued at 1.7 million bucks that's
like that's [ __ ] crazy that's at
least what we tell
well rounded up the everybody
yeah dude so uh man congrats on on on
everything dude thank you to be unranked
and as big of a star as you are
yeah people [ __ ] hate that i'm
unranked i this this kid fought i don't
know you watched adrian yeah yes i saw
the whole giannis thing
he had a fight sweet fight and he
tweeted march and i said march would be
sweet to fight him and uh
and then he did an interview after
someone and someone in the press
conference ask i listen to the whole
thing and he's like
he said i'm trying to fight ranked guys
why would i call him out i'm like dude
i mean i guess i i would call that peter
and dominic and pedro but it's like i
don't care if i fight a ranked guy like
that's not my next
let's let's get to what he really said
and it was very
very uh attacking it was hurtful yeah he
said he accused you of trying to dodge
rank to point opponents
yeah he he he was very he contradicted
himself he said i was trying to dodge
ranked opponents and that i was trying
to fight peter yawn and dominic cruz who
ranked guys he started trying to dodge
him and i was trying to fight him so i
think when he got asked about the
question he
got a little snake he's like [ __ ] yeah i
don't want to fight that guy like he he
acknowledged skills and then he
acknowledged that he wasn't very
impressed by my
very impressive knockouts over eddie
which the knockouts [ __ ] that that
knockout's legendary the thomas i made a
knockout i dropped him in the first let
him back up just so i could knock him
out again in the third
i literally watched that fight over this
morning it's just
i mean that was the one where it was the
walk off knockout but then but then the
the ref didn't stop it rightfully so
like he didn't stop he didn't need to
thomas almeida was still alive he was
still like looking i think he was
looking like where where the [ __ ] am i
but he was still like
there was no re he could have stopped it
he could have priced saved him about
a lot of damage um but it wasn't it i
mean it was the rest decision and the
ref made his decision i was fine with it
um do you know when you hit somebody
it's a knockout like is there a certain
like
feeling that happens yeah when i knocked
out eddie weinland uh
that one was nar that was the highlight
of all time but you know right when
you're connecting yeah oh yeah that one
was like in the home run you just feel
it right 100 it feels like a home run
just
dropped him and then but the the thomas
almeida one
you know i hit him i head kicked him
which was clean anybody was still
standing and i hit him with a left hand
and it didn't feel
like i dropped him but it didn't feel
like i put his lights out eddie weinland
was snore
literally snoring he was sleeping i
knocked him out right yeah and then the
eddie one
you uh
i mean it it was just like a you could
have finished him but he walked off
and then thomas uh okay then finished
him in the second round third third yeah
there you go my last two fights have
both been uh third round finishes with
like
not very much time left on the clock
does that bum you out finish them out in
the third or would rather get it done in
the first it doesn't matter to me like i
go back and watch all my fights so many
times like like actually i bet i watch
my fight more than anybody watches their
fights i just i love it i love watching
myself perform um
so if i finish them in the third round
it's like i gotta watch more like there
was there was a while there was knock
people out pretty fast in the first
round so i'd watch the fight and then go
to watch it again i'm like [ __ ] like
it's too quick like i already know
exactly what happens in each moment so
watching these ones that last a little
bit longer it's like it's more enjoyable
to go back and watch especially that
last fight the whole [ __ ] 14 and a
half minutes was just a highlight
yeah that was the one uh on the mcgregor
card yeah yeah with the green hair guy
yeah
and uh
yeah that kid
took so much abuse
but
he was throwing bombs as well i mean
right like it was a one-way war like i
didn't really get hit and i beat the
[ __ ] out of him understood
understood he was throwing ball he was
trying
he was throwing bombs i remember because
i was there
and uh of course i'm rooting for you
and i'm thinking
[ __ ] man if this kid's throwing [ __ ]
bombs if he catches if he catches he
could like
i it made me a little nervous he was
throwing such heat but you know your
movement was there like you didn't you
he didn't hit me too many times i wasn't
really too worried about his skill the
thing that was
most
his biggest skill was his cardio
especially for taking it on short notice
like it was right like
chin his chin and his cardio i mean that
that's like a shitty way to like
it's a shitty way to become popular like
he went from 3 000 to 130 000 followers
from literally getting the [ __ ] beat out
of him like it's not a good way to
become popular but he became popular he
did an interview a week later
and i don't know if he took if this was
just brain damage but he said he trained
eight days a week i'm like ah [ __ ]
what did i do what did i do to this poor
kid um nice kid
tough as [ __ ] and i'm looking forward to
his next fight like he's got an audience
now from getting beat up but hopefully
he can change that and maybe is he
fighting again soon he was supposed to
fight in october pulled out due to
injury which i think is good you know
what i mean he literally just got beat
up bad in july and then like september
october or august so when you fought
that kid you you walked out to a six
nine track do you what was that that
that that's kind of a controversial i
tell it don't do it uh yeah i do i think
his music is good i like it i remember
it because because i wasn't even sure i
was like is this six nine i believed
that a lot it's hard to tell it was like
i'm gonna be there at this next one ufc
369. six nines you'd be there i went out
with them right after the fight um i saw
you you caught some [ __ ] because you had
him
tattooing six nine on you oh yeah i did
get a lot of [ __ ] for that um yeah i
never like growing up i've never really
i mean i guess you care what people
think
in high school you're [ __ ] insecure
and everything but
i i care what people think man i get
very sensitive i do but i don't it's
like a weird like especially the more
popular i get and the more for whatever
reason money you get it's like you can
give less less [ __ ] like right i don't
i mean i did get a lot of heat from that
but then i still posted another picture
with them after and then like the
comments are the same [ __ ] like what are
you like what are you doing blah blah
blah but i'm not really doing things
just to please people of course
and i have no doubt that 69 is an
absolute sweetheart you know like i i'm
good buddies with steve will do it and
uh those two are always hanging out
together and and uh
steve will do it says nothing but just
the nicest things about him all the time
yeah i've still never met him but uh
well you'll be at two you see 269 right
you gotta be i you know what like dude
i'm on tour man i'm on this bus going
everywhere
should have scheduled it in vegas what's
that what's the date 269 december 11 11.
massive steve six the boys gonna be
there the elk boys are coming out i'm
bringing out all the all the celebrities
and i'm i'm still
unranked i'm i'm still on pay-per-views
i'll probably never not be on a
pay-per-view it's actually pretty crazy
to think dominic cruz versus pedro munoz
who are two top 10 bantamweights
dominick cruz was arguably one of the
best bantamweights of all time
are on my prelims now at this point i
called out dominick cruz dominic cruz
could have said yes to fighting me and
been on the main event our main card
which doesn't really [ __ ] matter i'm
not getting paid any more money to be on
the main card than if i was the first
fight of the night like it's not my job
to go out there and sell this fight it's
charles oliveira and dustin poyer
they're getting pay-per-view points i
don't know if both of them are or just
charles because he's the champ right i
think it's just the champion like
they're get he has to sell the fight i
don't have to sell a fight at in this
position so being on the main card and
being on the prelims i don't really know
it like it's similar to the rankings
like it doesn't really matter
but it kind of does it it depends what
uh how you look at it but it's just
crazy to think those two bantamweights
top ten
fighting for potentially title shots are
on the prelims and they said no and
dominic cruz had notified me i called i
did call both of them out i called
dominic cruz out and he made it known
like he did not he's not gonna fight me
for whatever reason obviously he's not
gonna say i don't wanna fight him
right like he said because i'm
not ranked or what like i don't it just
does it makes no sense to me how
they like to see you fight tj
tj tj's good tj cody cody's moving down
to 125 he'll be on that same card um
it's weird yeah cody's fighting at 25
now so it's like i don't even know how
realistic fighting him is anymore tj's
in my opinion one of the like after that
last fight
going into that fight i'm like we don't
know what tj we're gonna see we could
see a like uh oh [ __ ] that guy was
definitely using epo or we could right
or we could see the tj we saw which was
very very very [ __ ] impressive i
thought corey beat him
in damage i thought he won the fight but
tj was dealing with they got his acl or
whatever torn in the first or second
round and continued to fight five fives
it was very impressive
right yeah no that was definitely
steroids was on he was everything
needles in his butt i just can't wrap my
head around like
him actually doing that and thinking
like he's going to get away with it
unless he unless he had been doing it i
guess it's very expensive to test for
and they don't
the usada doesn't actually test for it i
think the athletic commission tested for
it which was kind of rare so i think he
would probably get away with it for a
while right why are they testing for
weed whoa scott randolph with the juicy
question does the ufc test for weed well
it seems to me that sometimes people
just don't want certain substances
involved in their program like hey i
personally don't want toxic ingredients
in my deodorant that's why i use native
deodorant man it's only quality
ingredients that i can pronounce which i
know what they are like coconut oil shea
butter i mean this stuff is just good
quality from good people and they don't
test on any animals they don't have
aluminum it's all just natural good
quality stuff and i use it and it's all
i use i love it i'm loyal to it and
they've got all these great scents man
plus special seasonal ones like for
christmas they're doing sugar cookie
mistletoe
candy cane hurry up and get it i'm
telling you plus i got a deal for you
you go to native
d o
that's native d
e o
dot com
stevo or just go to native nativedeo.com
and use the promo code stevo you're
going to get 20 off your first order and
you've got all great sense to choose
from you're going to figure out very
quickly why this is the only deodorant i
use and i feel good about it i smell
great it works great and it's going to
work great for you too so go to native d
e o dot com
stevo or just use the promo code stevo
to enjoy twenty percent off your first
order
now let's talk about weed
anymore just give like don't give a [ __ ]
about weed anymore
do you do you stop smoking pretty much
done at this point uh i find it a lot
easier to get my weight down because i
walk around around 157 um right now i'm
152 pounds and it and a lot of it's just
like cutting the weed out at night i get
the [ __ ] munchies like every single
time and i could be [ __ ] two days out
from weigh-ins and get high be like i
could just eat like they always [ __ ]
get you no matter what munchies will get
you
that's so funny that you you actually
told what your walking weight is now
most people don't like to talk about it
yeah it's weird i don't really i've
never
yeah i've never really uh understood why
like i think i i know why it's because
if if people uh admit what they're
walking around at then
they're uh
potentially
admitting that they're going to be
compromised when it comes time to fight
that's a good that's good i mean like i
could make a mc that could make sense i
i usually i'm actually lighter right now
going into this
these last couple weeks than i've ever
been just because my last like four or
five weight cuts there's been times
where i'm like i might [ __ ] die like
you're laying in that [ __ ] bath
friday morning trying to get the last
two pounds off and it's like
scary it's like [ __ ] and like everyone
i'm not just saying like bragging about
it like that's just what fighters deal
with you go you have to lose those last
two pounds friday morning and everyone's
different some people like what no i
don't i don't do but you know i'm a
pretty big bantamweight but right now
i'm i'm like two pounds less than i
usually am so i'm pretty excited about
fight week and going into the weight cut
um now
okay so
what about [ __ ]
all jermaine sterling
like
what about him it's such a big question
you know like he should change his name
to
i'm just here for the comments
yeah he's kind of got a it's tough
because he's he's one of the best in the
world like in the banter is he the champ
yeah he's the champion of the dq
but he was clearly getting worse okay
then the uh they last just fight for the
interim belt who
and then uh then he fought against it
was really weird that san hagen got that
interim belt i didn't think so i didn't
think so because i thought he beat tj
he's he's very he's like i mean if you
ask
the mma community like do you think he's
deserving of it every one of them would
have said yes as far as his skill what
he's done in the bantamweight division
um i i thought it was thought it thought
it was well deserved i mean it was
tricky because tj beat him but he
couldn't fight algo pulled out because
his neck it's like [ __ ] who's the next
guy rob font and jose aldo are already
fighting like he was the next guy
and he it was a really sweet fight him
for peter um but al joe yeah
poor al jo is like
comments are just [ __ ]
roasting i think they're getting to him
obviously i think i mean it's just
gnarly because now he's like
trying to like bring on hate you know i
mean i guess he was as soon as
as soon as he started like posing with
the belt it's like what else you're
gonna do you can't fight the comments
because they're all true you know
so much just it's just i mean it's kind
of bumming me out the way that he's like
just trying to turn everybody against
him is what it looks like and it's and
it doesn't like what matters is his next
performance like he's got to go out
there and beat peter he's got to and i
mean
looking back at their last fight it's
going to be a tough task peter
out wrestled him out struck him out
cardioed him out game planned him
besides the [ __ ] knee obviously but
uh
i i'm not counting aljo out of that
fight algae was a top bantamweight his
grappling is is very high level his
cardio like it was more of like a game
plan like you can't come out like a spaz
like that against peter young as a
[ __ ] killer who's
did just like
to beat corey the same way jose the same
way
like he comes out there very tight
defense very good defense and and kind
of lets you
use a lot of energy in the first couple
rounds and then picks it up like and al
joe completely [ __ ] used all of his
energy in the early rounds and then
completely gassed out so i think it's a
game plan error um but i'm not counting
him out of that fight i think you know
especially he's got to win that fight
he's got to go out there and win that
fight
um and shut everybody or the
comments are literally just going to be
worse
yeah
yeah dude
what's that like going into a fight for
you like the leading up to the fight are
you are have you already thought about
your game plan you're just trying to
keep busy until you get in the ring or
are you like
what are you thinking about as you're
walking into the ring
um
i get into a very like meta deep
meditative state so i get there we get
there an hour before and i'm constantly
just nasal breathing a lot like playing
with different breath holds like long
inhales long exhales long exhale holds
and just for like that whole hour i'm
very conscious of my breath and i feel
like i get into a
like a meditative state to where i'm
calm
but i'm ready to kill like it's like in
kills like this guy's trying to kill me
i'm trying to kill him you know i think
if you ever see any backstage footage of
me
i'm sitting there
very calm like
just meditating um and then when i hit
mids i'm conscious of my my breath the
whole time
so walking out i'm just you know feeling
my breath and it just it helps me get in
to get into my breath and out of my head
i'm not overthinking anything i'm not
nervous i'm not you're not nervous no i
i haven't been nervous for a fight in a
long time i'm nervous
my hands watching
sweaty just hearing you dude i get
nervous watching like people that i care
about fight um
it's right my girl and i can't
we almost can't take it when doug rose
fights i know well she like makes you
[ __ ] nervous because she looks like
she's about to have a melt now and i'm
like oh god i don't know if she should
be in there but she's the best in the
[ __ ] world like she dared she's so
pretty
she's so rad dude it's trippy watching
her walk out because it's like it's just
super emotional it's like she's like
wearing her emotions on the outside
right which is
everyone does their own thing it makes
it works for her she's a [ __ ] beast
and then where's your head at like in
the fight like are you
thinking about movies and doing it or is
it like instinct and like something
happens you're like oh that was cool
that i just did like i didn't even plan
i can't even answer that because i feel
like i'm not in the cage i just
completely let go and have like a higher
i just trust that the last six weeks
seven eight weeks whatever it was that
the work was put in and i completely
just
like autopilot almost flow state
i just i just whatever happens happens
and i just completely let go of
all thought and i mean that's the goal
and i feel like i've been pretty good at
that and i think my performances show
that um but yeah if you're thinking in
there you're a step behind you got to be
flowing and just
it's a it's a
second i'd be like tom cruise is in the
audience [ __ ] dude cindy crawford oh my
god like that happens like there's split
seconds where there's things like that
happen
like like like tom like somebody will
catch your eye or no not even i feel
like that last fight i was just so
[ __ ] locked in and dialed in and
thankfully i was because that kid
[ __ ] brought it like i needed every
ounce of energy that i used in there to
to whoop that dude's ass and it worked
but i remember i'm trying to think back
like
i i do remember like seeing someone one
time in a fight and thinking like oh and
then like snap back into it
but after was it i don't remember but i
do after my last fight i went back and
rewatched it
and uh and i saw trump already in the
audience when you were fighting i didn't
see trump but i've seen bieber and
bieber in the in the video the last like
45 seconds the crowd went crazy and i'm
dotting this dude up bieber and his dad
stand up and like i thought that was the
coolest [ __ ] thing ever that one of
the best performers in the world justin
bieber
was like standing up in awe of what i
was doing and i was like
that was sick like that was cool that
was cool he brought him to his feet
brought him to his feet and like the
whole arena was standing up it was that
was pretty crazy i mean it's weird
you're you're a savage gladiator like
i mean people are watching you
entertain them by [ __ ] somebody up
yeah and they're like yep it's weird
fighting such a weird [ __ ] sport it's
like looking at it now that i'm in camp
like if you if we were doing this
podcast two weeks after my fight
like i feel like i'd be i'm a different
person like a lot of people have way
different conversations obviously we're
talking about the fight now but like the
last six weeks i've been in camp which
is like no drinking sleeping good eating
clean training hard like just like i'm a
different person inside of camp and
outside of camp do you normally drink
quite a bit
after that last fight i went i think in
out of the eight weeks i drank like six
weekends in a row which was a lot for me
and i'm like there was like when i went
to miami with steven six like thursday
friday saturday we went hard three
nights in a row and that was [ __ ]
crazy but
i don't even want to go i don't even
after my fight i'm sure we'll drink go
like have the after party i'm like i
don't i i think back like even last
night i was thinking of some of the [ __ ]
i was doing when i was drunk and i'm
like that's embarrassing like what the
[ __ ] i was like acting like that but in
the moments like you're drunk everyone's
drunk everyone's acting a fool but i'm
like i don't even know if i like that
about me like i'm like but then again
it's just like i was i was celebrating
having fun whatever wherever we're at
doing whatever but yeah alcohol is a
weird thing
after you win and like you're walking
back are you like all right i'm about to
blaze it like what are you like
usually like can't wait for that first
load i don't like smoking and drinking
like mixing i don't like mixing those
two um because if i smoke i'm wanting to
chill the [ __ ] out yeah and like usually
after the fight it's like okay now it's
like we got to go out to the club we i
have an after party gotta go see the
boys gotta go you know we gotta
celebrate um
if i if right after the fight if i
smoked i would literally be in the hotel
room [ __ ] eating not giving a [ __ ]
about anything like just chilling yeah
so usually after the fight it's like
it depends this one might be different i
know i have an after party that's gonna
be you know at a club so i'm sure we're
not that you know take some shots but
i'm gonna try last time after that last
fight was the first time i blacked out
oh wow i feel like that was terrifying
like i'm like [ __ ] dude i don't that was
dangerous i feel like we were texting
after your last fight and there's dude
probably yeah
everybody he sent you dick pics
dude dad that's so funny man um
so you said you've been in camp for uh
for
like six weeks i i've been part of a gym
that like a bunch of other like mma
legends are part of i train in a couple
different gyms i train i do my sparring
at the mma lab
benson that's like benson henderson's
gym who's who's a legend in the sport um
also a bunch of kyler phillips trains
there he's in the uc mario but he's the
casey kenny like there's a bunch of guys
that are in the ufc and then there's
guys there's young tyler phillips is uh
the heavyweight no kyler that's uh tyler
phillips is the kid that
fought the kid that i'm about to fight
last night okay and uh but there's jared
cannanier who's like a scary
[ __ ] there's like that's at the
mma lab bunch of killers there and then
i train at tim's gym um i usually just
hit mitts with tim there and do some
grappling and then uh augusto mendes
who's like one of the best grapplers in
the world he has a gym in tempe so i go
to three different gyms and then my
strength and conditioning coaches
brandon harris in scottsdale so i go to
like four different gyms
total but yeah i've been in camp for
pride like six weeks so this is like a
longer camp for me um because we still
have a couple weeks left
and your your main coach is your uh
podcast co-host yep tim tim's like
my
you could call him a head coach he he
holds he's like my striking coach and uh
he so doesn't look like a fighting
personality tim yeah i had no idea he
was your coach when i was on your
podcast a lot of people yeah a lot of
people
say that that's funny um yeah we [ __ ]
we we're like really good friends and he
he basically the other head coach i feel
like for me it's like i run my camps
like i pick my i do my schedule i know
like no one has to hold me accountable
like hey did you do your sprints today
hey dude are you eating good hey are you
sleeping like no one has to hold me
accountable in that sense to where i'm
like i run my own camps and then like i
tell tim like hey we're hitting mitts at
this time like i so i kind of run my own
camps
how do you find out you're a good
fighter is it from like getting in
fights in high school and you're just
like a good question
scott's on fire
scott randolph really is on fire folks
and so am i man i am just about ready to
take the stage at this sold out show on
stevo's bucket list tour and before i
get on stage i like to make sure that i
have cleaned my pipes by taking a full
dump and no full dump is complete
without washing your butthole properly
and you know how i like to do that with
my bidet from hello tushy you've
probably heard me say it that
hellotushy.com is my absolute favorite
sponsor of the wild ride podcast it's
because it's changed my life it's made
pooping my favorite part of the day
and they just came out with the tushy
ace which is a whole toilet seat that
you can mount onto your toilet get rid
of the old crappy toilet seat and put on
the tushy ace and it has a remote
control so before you sit down to take
your dump you push a button and you've
got that toilet seat at the temperature
that you've chosen then when you get
done taking your sloppy dump you push
another button and boom you got this
refreshing stream of water
blasting your [ __ ] just power
cleaning it nice and fresh and clean and
when you get done doing that push
another button and out comes the blow
dryer to blow dry your butthole nice and
dry oh man best experience ever and you
can get 10 off if you go to
hellotushy.com
stevo
telling you it is my favorite thing i
have ever promoted on this podcast and
it's gonna be the favorite gift of
anybody you buy it for you go to
hellotushy.com
stevo
for 10 off your order
and to be among the very first people to
experience the tushy ace it's gonna
change the way you think about your
butthole it's gonna make your life way
better so jump on that and let's talk
about fighting
so i was just an athlete growing up
played soccer basketball football
baseball
like
all season like every season and that's
in montana in montana so it's like i'm
going against [ __ ] scrubs so i
thought i'm just like this elite athlete
but really it's like i'm playing against
[ __ ] dildos um but uh yeah so i when
i was 16 years old my buddy asked me to
go check out this fighting gym and i go
and it's basically kickbox sparring like
throwing gloves and i'm now i'm hitting
mitts and sparring like a couple classes
in and i was doing really good i'm like
oh [ __ ] and i was doing good because i
was an athlete and it's like i wasn't i
didn't have great boxing skills i wasn't
throwing like proper jabs and one twos i
was just an athlete and like
competent for whatever reason and i just
kind of was naturally good at it and i
was beating up people in montana so i
didn't realize there was levels at the
gym
at the gym yeah i wasn't i never really
gotten street fights um i i didn't
really like confrontation to be honest i
was kind of just super insecure that's
why i started fighting was pick up
chicks right right that makes sense in
high school insecure like [ __ ] probably
do everything yeah so uh
yeah i just found out i was good just by
go
beating people up basically started had
four kickboxing fights when i was 16
years old and [ __ ] was like knocking
people out around montana so i was like
damn
what was the first fight where we
realized like oh this guy's actually
like really good um
like an actual skilled fight
i don't know it's a good question i've
had like 35 fights in my life so i've
had a lot of fights um i'd say it
probably took a while to well until i
actually fought someone with true skill
like oh [ __ ] this guy's actually pretty
good um
a lot of the people i knocked out early
in the first round too so i didn't know
if they were like i don't i just caught
for whatever i just such good timing
it's not like a hit hard it's not like
i'm like [ __ ] but you get them like
right here
there's a couple sweet spots right on
that jaw like behind the ears a good
spot
um there's a couple sweet spots but it's
not like i hit hard like derek lewis
pray hits hard mine's more like speed
and timing he's like shutting the lights
out
um so there's a lot of guys i thought
that were probably pretty good that i
dropped in the first round and if i got
called uh i don't know in the first time
i was like damn this guy's good yeah
when uh
that uh you know
big crazy like iconic snoop dogg is
screaming your name was that when you
were on the contender series yeah snoop
will never call me sugar shawn it's
always sugar shane every time every time
like he was on rogan podcast shigeshan
i've heard him say it probably about
three or four other times which is funny
and it's like
who am i to correct [ __ ] snoop yeah
yeah but uh yeah that was legendary and
uh so then
if anybody doesn't know you're fighting
and it's just this incredible
performance and snoop
shut up
yeah oh my god yellow mountain
oh man and
and so then you got the fight with
cheeto vera coming up and uh and you
post snoop screaming o'malley and you
caption it this is cheetos girlfriend
right yeah those are cheetos cheetos
you know like screaming his name
i remember thinking that that was
unnecessary
that was definitely unnecessary um but
then again you know that's part of the
deal it could be you could
look at it how you want it could be like
an entertainment aspect like oh [ __ ] he
crossed the line which you know people
get more invested in the fight or you
can look at it like damn the [ __ ]
[ __ ] and that was too far which you
know it might have been too far i
actually forgot about that until you
just brought it up
i do remember
doing that now but yeah
um
i mean it's far less controversial than
the outcome of that fight
yeah like uh if if we're honest so
that like and you to this day maintain
that you're undefeated yeah and that's
like
like like what's the philosophy in that
yeah um
so you go out there and two guys get in
a fist fight and it lasts 15 minutes and
then it's like not controversial it's
like that dude won it's like that that's
a win or you go out there and and i
knock someone out clean like eddie
weinless it's not like i don't know it
was or or the last fight chris martinez
beat his ass like those aren't those are
clearly like the better man won that
fight was just like
like how many times i've been kicked in
the leg from that fight even till now
you know probably 100 times got kicked
like every time i fought someone after
that fight it's like kick him in the leg
kick him like kick in the leg
like my legs just gonna go numb his
literally his big toe
hit like the nerve behind my knee and my
foot went completely numb and i was
dragging my foot across the octagon and
i blitzed in on him like through a combo
which i shouldn't have done because my
foot wasn't [ __ ] working but i
blitzed it was still dotting his ass up
um
and i and i fell to my back my foot was
completely numb he got on top through an
elbow ref stopped to fight
um it was i didn't i just didn't feel
like
okay and and i i i'm with all that i i
don't uh
i'm not hating on the
on the philosophy
but
i think that if you're gonna take that
position that we should see a cheeto
rematch i agree yeah no totally i agree
i think he just came out and said that
um
fighting these backwards or something
it's just so weird to me these guys is
like he's saying to step backwards
trying to go back and fight you again
yeah when i'm clearly one of the biggest
stars in the ufc like for him to say
that or even adrian is to say that he
wants more money to fight me it's like i
am the more money like not actually more
money but i'm the you beat me you get
like cheetos popular because he beat me
like chris mcdean is popular because i
beat his ass like you don't just get
more money to fight me that is your more
money he's fighting me it's your
opportunity um so for cheeto to say that
it's a step backwards makes absolutely
no sense um what'd you think of uh
cheeto and frankie edgar frankie was a
couple like a minute away from winning
that fight i didn't think it was like a
dominant win like it was it could i mean
i think it's in new york it's it's
frankie edgar i think frankie gets that
win a minute left in that fight um it
wasn't like an impressive performance
but cheeto he did what he needed to do i
mean he landed the kick uh
i got him again dude that [ __ ] kick
was beautiful and did you see that still
image ooh they have his face
oh my god what's still image it's a
still image of frankie edgar's face as
cheetos front kick connected and it
looks like
just a bad caricature it does it's
[ __ ] it fight like those slope those
pictures like that look fake it's crazy
it's it's the most striking image from
ufc i think i've ever seen wow yeah
it's it's wild yeah a lot of people like
like if you ask cheeto if he likes me or
not he would he does he hates me he like
doesn't like me at all he like it's very
personal for him i've never
i don't feel like anyone's like personal
like
i don't know i see it just as an
entertainment business um sure and and
but it's funny like
yeah it's funny to me that he gets so
emotional and people bring me up like he
hates me he really doesn't like me but i
feel like a lot of that's like he knows
deep down he did it it's not like it's
probably why well i mean i think that
if i understand cheeto and i like cheeto
i like him a lot um he's got like what
he describes as the immigrant mentality
you know this like
just
this fierce
fire and passion and and like
and so i
i take it that he's got that level of
emotion just around everything you know
and like when i see him
uh
you know like sometimes it strikes me
that like he lacks sportsmanship you
know like in uh in the way he goes on
like after a fight and yeah i don't want
to be like dude like yeah don't do that
and he's like i can't help it i'm
[ __ ] it's ecuador dude like i'm the
immigrant exactly you know like yeah and
so i i like that i like that and um i i
just think that he takes everything
personally yeah and i think he does
that's probably not
good for some people and it's just so
crazy how different everybody is totally
you know like some people
have a kid they become a dad and then
that just makes them the best fighter
and then other people become a dad and
yeah i mean i've i've have my baby just
turned one it's been [ __ ] definitely
been crazy like it's
changes you for sure
dude
it's intense and then some people are
like
[ __ ] terrified before they get in the
octagon huh dude some yeah everyone's so
different like rose seems terrified like
carlos spars is like basically crying
before she gets into the fire
and then yeah there's some guys are just
calm some guys are fired up like pump
jacked like
you can see it some guys
have heard crazy stories about cowboy
cowboy i mean even i think nate diaz
pukes before the fight in the back
cowboy says he's [ __ ] terrified which
i thought was the dumbest thing ever to
say fight week against conor mcgregor
cowboy comes out he's like yeah i
[ __ ] i'm terrified walking out there
like you don't say that when you're
about to fight conor like
now you caught her standing across the
cage from you knowing you're [ __ ]
terrified like that probably wasn't the
best thing to say cowboy's a [ __ ]
legend dude cowboy cowboy i do
um so i don't want to act sound like i'm
talking [ __ ] but
yeah everyone's just [ __ ] different
yeah dude it's like me going up on stage
i'm terrified every time i go up on
stage i make him open for me
i hate public speaking
i would be that's one thing i would be
[ __ ] terrified of dude what are you
up to tonight i know i was talking to
him too and i was telling him like my my
schedule like my bedtime's like i'm in
bed at 8 30 like up at seven i know i
would love to go i miss a jack harlow
concert recently too because he was in
town and asked me i'm like [ __ ] i just i
can't dude i can't do it yeah i get it i
would love to come out though you got a
show tonight
when do you decide uh when you're gonna
dye your hair for the fight my girl does
my hair she loves like she loves doing
my hair she she does hair for a living
so she's always kind of like playing
with different hair so whatever you want
go ahead pretty much i'm like whatever
you think is gonna look sweet like i
think we're gonna do like this color
with a pink i like that color yeah the
rainbow was fine
that was the first one that was like six
nine inspired too like that was right
the first time i did it and that was
that was i asked six when the first time
he he uh saw me was and he said that
fight someone's like hey this kid's got
the same hair uh and that was the first
time he he had saw me fight and then
knocked out eddie which is pretty cool
yeah the hair is [ __ ] fun to play
around with it's just like
we got to be different in the sport i
mean you've done such a good job of
having like a name and a brand and like
being this celebrity within the sport
was that at all intentional or are you
just kind of like that kind of guy
yeah like but i wanted to be
when i was young young in montana like i
wanted to be in the nfl like when i was
delusional and you didn't i didn't
understand i wasn't gonna be six four
like i want to be in the nfl and i'm
like okay that's not gonna happen i
wanna be famous how am i gonna do that i
don't [ __ ] know i don't have any like
crazy skills and i found fighting and i
was like oh maybe i can just put on
performances that way and it kind of
like built like that and then seeing
connor
blow up like two years before
two or three years before i went pro i'm
like oh [ __ ] like i kind of had that
vision for myself like i wanted to
transcend the sport and like be that guy
and then conor did it before me so now i
know what to not do because connor's
kind of going crazy a little bit so it's
like kind of like uh yeah it's
making it really difficult to like him
i know i'll always look at conor's
connor knocked out aldo in 13 seconds
beat eddie alvarez like just sure but
yeah i mean yeah it's who knows where
his head's at
and then leg kicks changed the game yeah
i mean that one it was weird because
before that watching the embeddeds
watching his like the videos he was
putting out before that fight i remember
seeing him like get do his sessions and
then go sit in his chair and then put
his ank those his ankle in the ice bath
and i was like damn i wonder if he's
dealing with ankle shin some kind of
injury
and he sure as [ __ ] he said is like she
was it was already [ __ ] up but dude
that's what happened sparring is where
you get your injuries dude like
it's just part of the sport you want a
lot some people's
i have to spar and in camp i spar out of
camp i don't in camp i gotta spar make
sure you know that's where you that's
where you can get your confidence from
where you know your cardio is at where
you can trust your trust the work that's
been put in is is paying off but
also deal comes with injuries like
he injured that in sparring and then
it's part of the you know what happened
what happened in the fight
do dudes at bars ever try to like ask
you to knock him out or i i don't really
not on the bars but i stream on twitch
like every single day and i pretty much
have someone say that every [ __ ] day
dude knock me out like i don't wanna i
don't like hurting people like i don't
want to knock someone out unless it's
for fat money
that's interesting man is the twitch a
video game deal yeah i just i play i
mean i've been playing video games my
entire life and i started streaming like
four years ago and it's like one of my
favorite [ __ ] things it's like one of
the things i look forward to pretty much
like most in the day is getting on with
the boys put the headset on and you got
your for you got your squad and you're
[ __ ] in this virtual reality for two
hours it feels like 30 minutes and
you're just gaming and you're that's a
meaningful revenue stream too
yeah it's i mean yeah you could
definitely
make a living off it yeah i mean dude i
remember when i was on your podcast i
told you about what uh
danny trejo had said to us about
fighting where's he said uh
fight like uh
the the fighting gods are extremely
jealous you know like they're they're if
you if you if you give your attention to
anything but fighting then they'll
they'll punish you for that and they'll
take everything away and i thought that
was pretty interesting because we've
seen so many people turn their attention
like you know ronda rousey famously
she's as soon as she's talking about i'm
going to be an actor like yeah he would
listen
i heard max holloway stream like a
hundred hours he's he streams too he
games yeah same should i do 100 hours in
his fight camp which is probably twice
as much if not more than how much i
stream and then he goes out there and
does what he does i'm like right [ __ ]
yeah right you guys are happy
and uh
you know you i remember
thinking like
you know
like
you you almost seem to be striving to
divert your attention to other things
you know to like you know
accomplish celebrity and and all this
stuff but
it seems to be going really well for you
yeah in camp i'm dialed in i'm locked in
like i'm not i'm not doing stuff that i
shouldn't be doing like you're doing
podcasts
once a week yeah well i do i do two one
one on sunday and one on like wednesday
it's like they're an hour it's like this
like this takes no this isn't crazy like
i'm just [ __ ] talking it's
um but yeah that and then i stream like
uh thursday friday saturday sunday so i
stream less in camp
um
basically just train recover train
recover
that's basically all camp life is and it
gets [ __ ] boring like
if you
if the kids say they want to be fighters
and stuff it's like you gotta be like
okay i'm gonna be sore for oh every day
monday thursday like maybe not sunday i
might not be sore probably though
and i'm not gonna do much like i'm gonna
be at home chilling and i'm gonna be
sore every like that's fighter life a
hundred percent for fight camp
yeah
you said you had three fights left in
your contract yeah how do you see those
playing out fighting in uh obviously
fighting in december paiva i would love
to fight yanez february march and then i
have one more fight on the contract um
april may pride june july cody garbrandt
could be he's he's gone
but we'll see where how this fight plays
out with kai kar france he's got to win
this fight he he'll be like one in 37 if
he loses he's got to win this [ __ ]
fight like he's has to win this fight um
kykar france hasn't been winning
everything i'm not sure about i know of
the name car friends but i'm not sure
from um
from addison yeah i couldn't tell you
who he fought ever like i know his name
i just don't know who he's fought i
don't know if he doesn't have a winning
record you'll see i don't know i don't
know anything about him um but yeah
cody's got to win this fight he's got to
like he i mean
he goes that's really cool man
you know like i bring up all joe and
bring up cody and uh you're
just evidently supportive of of these
competitors yeah and i think like with
the cody thing it's like if you lose i
would like to fight cody someday i think
it'll be a massive fight like i'm in the
business i won't put on massive fights
me and cody
if he wins and keeps winning like we
could be a pay-per-view me and peter
young could be a massive pay-per-view me
and corey like we could there's all
these guys could be massive
pay-per-views if we all just keep
winning so yeah i want cody to go out
there and win he's got a name already
it's like me and kai carr francine's in
the pay-per-view like me and cody could
be a massive pay-per-view so it's like
these guys
i want to see them win so i could fight
them and it makes sense you know
i like that dude and like i said i don't
take anything perfectly and cody about
beef on twitter and stuff and it's like
it's entertainment beef but it's also
like he he does he probably takes it
personal too maybe like cheeto or maybe
they don't maybe they see it like man
like it's entertainment like but uh for
i mean he's gonna be at the hotel same
same as me fight week so it's like we
you see if it's personal to them like
interesting elevator rides yeah
ufc does a good job putting like because
they bought the whole [ __ ] hotel they
bought a hotel for for vegas so they do
a good job putting people like not next
to each other
right yeah and who's who's cody fighting
ty car france oh that okay of course
yeah yeah all right at 125. so it's his
debut at 25. yeah
why wouldn't you fight up like why would
you want to deal with the weight cut
because it's very big he probably walks
around i think he's 150 148 149 which is
like if you walk around that way you
could make 125. but why wouldn't you why
would you want to go through a weight
cut why wouldn't you want to just light
and chill cody's chin is an issue you
know like you can't get knocked out like
that and then if you look at when when
tj came down to flyweight like [ __ ]
he did not bring his chin with him
i think cody's chin i don't think it's
too
i think like the shots that he ate from
tj both times
tj was cheating he's on epo
allegedly i don't know like in those
fights
which is a huge advantage it's like hard
to judge his chin off that pedro munoz
hits hard knocked him out too then he
just fought rob five five-minute rounds
ate some clean shots didn't get knocked
out um got his ass kicked rob font who's
a [ __ ] stud who's kind of under the
radar not like a super popular fighter
but a [ __ ] stun boxing super super
slick boxing
man beat his ass beat cody's ass i
re-watched that fight the other day and
cody's he's got a chin he [ __ ] ate
some big shots um
so yeah i i don't think going down to 25
is gonna be good for his chin though you
when you cut weight like that you lose
brain fluid and brain fluid takes the
longest to hydrate from and we get about
i don't know 30 hours or whatever it is
to rehydrate which who knows if that's
really enough time to
get that brain back especially for cody
but i don't know if kycar france is like
a knockout guy but still in those little
gloves it only takes [ __ ]
one little shot dude the the ufc when
when uh the venom contract began they
sent me this official ufc fight kit and
when i felt those [ __ ] gloves i was
like wait what the little rocks they're
so hard dude yeah they're not to protect
people's chains they protect your
knuckles like they're not serious i was
like
is it safe for going in the bare knuckle
fighting
do you probably get cut more in bare
knuckle fighting just from sliding but
you don't hit as hard because you don't
want to break your knuckles right you
would you
i i don't know i wouldn't [ __ ] do
better knocking no matter what i never
would i think it's [ __ ]
i don't know they said that i don't
remember who was telling me they said
the wraps though they they wrapped their
hands still and it's like a [ __ ] cast
but i don't know how i don't know i
don't i wouldn't do it [ __ ] that i mean
you know like because everybody who bare
knuckle fights it's like mike perry is
going to walk out of there with a
smashed face both both parties you're
going to walk in there with a smash face
i like mike perry i like he's very
likable yeah [ __ ] yeah he is i
mike perry did that when he won with his
[ __ ] girl as his corner man
that was the best well i think he he
what he
walked out to halo by beyonce but he
asked for halo the theme song like
and i think he just came out like
singing it i i think i seen that
somewhere online
dude do you know what song you're going
to walk out to for the next fight um a
69 is going to be there steve will do is
going to be there i think uh i don't
know if six gonna have some new some
unreleased music i can walk out to or
something i don't know yeah probably
some price i'm sick that's fun yeah dude
i'm backing it so i gotta ask i'm a
super casual ufc fan like i know who you
are you know
but like this
but the fact that you're unranked is
hard for me to wrap my head around like
at what point do you become ranked how
does that even work yeah i mean i guess
beating ranked opponents you become
ranked fight dude if we're honest the
ranking system is kind of [ __ ]
[ __ ] because how often do you see
somebody who's higher ranked than their
opponent yet the odds are like a
landslide for the less ranked person the
guy i'm the guy i'm fighting when i
announced the fight he was ranked number
15. that's the rankings go from 1 to 15
like in the ufc so he was ranked number
15.
two weeks later
he's out of the ranking so it's like if
i win this fight do i get ranked 15 or
do i just stay unranked but i've never
cared about rankings i i just really
don't adrian yanez isn't ranked i i want
to fight him next um so it's like
the rankings are i don't really even
know who makes the rankings i don't know
if like someone at the ufc or if it's
someone on a commission or like it just
really never made sense to me i remember
when
i mean it totally although he
respectfully can be ranked in the
bantamweight division he moved down to
the bantamweight lost i think lost a
fight he was ranked like six i'm like
i mean dude what pyotr yawn did to aldo
was really disturbing peter yawn is he's
powerful pound i think he's right behind
camaro right now i think he's up there
like one of the best in the world damn
so there's not like a mathematical
equation of you won the x fights against
this person so now you're right
someone's just kind of making that
decision i i think that popularity has a
big
big role in it
yeah and i think yeah it depends you
gotta beat like like i said this kid
isn't ranked so if i beat him will they
put me at 15 they could like they very
well could put me at rank number 15 if i
go out there and beat him
or the or not like i said though like
don't matter like yeah i mean you're
rocking the merch it's like yeah you get
wrestling
yeah i got unranked this is my 15th
about to be my 15th dub and then on the
back says champ on ranked champ i feel
like
like i'm the unranked i'm a champ in my
division everyone
if if there was if all of the
bantamweights were fighting on one night
you said you have to watch one they're
all fighting at the same time i
guarantee i'll have more than anybody i
guarantee that people are watching my
fight more than anyone else's and that's
kind of what the unranked champ means
yeah yeah you're a pay-per-view draw for
sure yeah and i don't get pay-per-view
points it's tough
but it's it's fine like
that connor dustin poirier if i conor
should have slid me over like a little
percentage i sell pay-per-view i
guarantee there's people that buy the
pay-per-view just to watch me that don't
really know charles oliveira or dustin
poirier yeah justin poured a [ __ ]
star i can't say that
dustin's the man dustin's respectfully
it's weird that
charles the champ and dustin's not
right now but charles is a [ __ ]
he's one of my favorites to watch
charles was dustin that fight's gonna be
so [ __ ] sweet dude i'm so excited i
gotta watch that yeah yeah that fight's
gonna be exciting so wait so you see
you're gonna be oh you'll have already
fought so i'll fight and it sucks right
now that we have to so i i fight and
then i go do probably an hour i have to
stay there for an hour doing interviews
medical doing a bunch of stuff and then
we have to drive the hotel so i'll get
there like right around the co-main main
um
do you pay attention to the uh the odds
on your fights
i [ __ ] i not really like some people
tell me hey you're my you're this favor
my minus whatever i still like you could
tell i've been told minus plus whatever
means this and that and i still just
[ __ ] don't know
i don't know what they mean
but yeah i know i don't really pay
attention to it do you know what i am
this fight like i don't i don't either
do you bet on fights i don't yeah i mean
i did one of these my bookie uh
promotions and for that like i felt like
i owned the intent
yeah i parlayed all four fights i had
you to win and then i won like 1500
bucks that that's sweet yeah i mean it's
fun like i i'm i can't i have a tough
time gambling for whatever reason like
yeah it's just like [ __ ] i don't want to
lose 20 bucks right when i game though
every single game when i play call of
duty i'll play for two hours i'll play
probably 10 games every game we put like
five dollars on the line though and it
makes it so much more fun and i don't
mind losing five bucks here and there
actually like but for gambling on sports
is hard yeah not 20. no gambling on
sportscar because i have no control of
it gaming it's like okay if i i can play
good i know i can't so how does the
twitch stream rank against the podcast
for how much money you're bringing in um
that's a good question i would say
twitch stream probably makes
um
depends you know some some pods you get
sponsors sometimes sometimes we're just
running just straight just because we're
doing a podcast for the people like
we're getting a couple hundred bucks ad
revenue from youtube nothing crazy so it
depends if you get a sponsors that week
that month um but i think even if we do
i'll probably make more money on twitch
okay yeah twitches
you said merch is going pretty sweet
yeah
merch has been [ __ ] something i've
always been interested in like even my
earlier fights when i when i was an
amateur in helena we were doing like
just shitty merch but we were still i
was still selling merch so still like
pushing it hard like selling it to just
at the fights so merch has been
something i've been kind of passionate
about since the beginning of fighting
and now it's like oh i have a big
company actually helping me and it's
like yeah merch is doing really good the
new stuff drops friday when does this
come out what's the name
doesn't come out a week from thursday
[ __ ] yeah so merch will be out by then
um yeah can they get it
thank you for asking
shop.co or sugarshow.com i think either
one i think they're both linked to it
that's cool and you said you're from
montana and steve we got shows coming up
in the world
i know you said that
i got bombs
i got great falls coming up i got
missing coming up
great falls the great falls that's where
tim's from oh cool man my buddy ryan
simonetti is from grapevine that'll be
cool montana trip will be fun it's it's
different it's [ __ ] different i've
been out there yeah i've only driven
through it but i was like staring out
the window i've been happier and and i i
had a good time
um and so what what about like sponsors
just in general are you on the monster
squad yep monster squad um my day one
like sponsor from i think contender
series through my entire ufc career has
been sanible um the guy that owns
sanibel emron who's pretty much like
my biggest like mentor someone i talk to
pretty much every day like he's
one of the nicest people i've ever met
it's rare in the sport where you can
meet someone that truly wants what's
best for you and doesn't really ask for
anything in return it's like very very
[ __ ] rare so monster sanible um king
palm dr dabber those four right now are
like my my biggest sponsors that have
been with me for a while monster i just
recently signed with but they're but
they're already hooking me up and
helping they're gonna completely mad out
my entire gym and uh pimp it out
nice man so
all of that put together
is it safe to say that you get more
money from sponsors than from actual ufc
fights i would say this year i'll
probably make more money from yeah from
sponsor just from outside the ufc i've
made a good amount of money in the ufc
which is in turn
allowed me to be able to make a lot of
money from sponsors because that's where
i became popular that's how i get views
is from the ufc so i can't
hate on ufc pays in a sense like because
they gave me the opportunity to uh
to get sponsors i remember when i'd
started uh with jackass on mtv like the
first season of jackass i made a total
of 1500
bucks after after taxes
yeah and i was like you know what
[ __ ] let them not pay me because
they're gonna make me into a monster and
they did i'm gonna [ __ ] did yeah
that's i mean that's
it's all perspective thing like you can
get some guys and like i've really kind
of had to learn about that perspective
because i was kind of upset about my pay
too i feel like i'm a star i should make
more or whatever but then i'm like [ __ ]
got to look at it this way too like i'm
i'm the reason i have making more
outside the ufc is because i'm in the
ufc
still like
it's it's whatever i don't i don't want
to talk bad about the ucf they've helped
like i would not
like my whole
generally not a good idea it's not a
good idea
i also owe the ufc everything because
they [ __ ] have given me the platform
and the opportunity to perform because
at the end of the day i just love
performing in front of [ __ ] crowds
and i don't know what i could perform i
can't go and [ __ ] make people laugh
um but i can't fight during the pandemic
with no crowds three times yeah fought
in the apex three times i fought eddie
um oh yeah
cheeto and the thomas almeida yeah and
you obviously like fighting with crowds
better i prefer it yeah for sure not no
does it affect the performance of like
when it's quiet versus it's not me some
people it might but and i'm just in a
different [ __ ] zone in there but i
prefer the crowd you like how i did this
like any [ __ ] idea what i'm doing i
thought you were a trainer
i'm like there's a strong argument for
being able to hear your coaches without
the crowds
yeah for the most part um
like i'm definitely listening to see
here like that that's
like tim knows my style more than
anybody like besides me so he's like
having eyeballs on the outside of the
cage i'm definitely kind of listening to
if he's hearing if he sees something
that i don't see i'm definitely listen
for it but for the most part i'm [ __ ]
in control and just like
setting things up doing my own thing but
there's definitely been times where i've
heard tim say something and like here
boom boom and then i threw it and it
[ __ ] lands and it's been you know
powerful but it's yeah man i feel like
there's this fight you have coming up
paivo i feel like he had some crazy
fight of the night last fight against
kyler my buddy yeah jesus pipe yeah
cream paiva
[Laughter]
no yeah it's crazy for me to be in this
situation because i'm
so i'm a popular fighter i'm very well
known so then i go fight a guy named
piva who no one [ __ ] knows he just
had a cr and he's good as [ __ ] yeah i
saw that [ __ ] dude he had a [ __ ]
war incredible
a war and i and and to be honest i
thought i lost i thought my buddy won
not even being biased i really just
believe i mean he dropped him twice in
the first round it's got to be a 10-8
worse comes the worst it was a draw but
um i think the dude's a [ __ ] stud
like i got a legitimate badass in front
of me and people are just like oh you're
gonna knock him out like yeah that's the
plan that's the goal i'm gonna i
definitely believe i can do it i'm
capable of it but people don't
understand like i'm still fighting
[ __ ] studs like this dude's a stud he
may not be ranked he was number
um but or be very popular so people just
write him off like oh
win which i'm you know not mad at it but
i'm fine
the dude doesn't have any range right
like you're gonna have like he's i think
he's uh i think i'm gonna have a little
bit longer reach than him i'm gonna be
way [ __ ] faster than him um and i
believe you know he's a black belt jiu
jitsu i think he might try to grapple me
a little bit i think i'm gonna be able
to keep the fight standing it's in the
big octagon which is very helpful for me
because i like i like to dance on people
i like to make people look stupid i like
dribbling on [ __ ] you remember
that blah blah blah and i hit him with
the one too i like just entertaining and
having [ __ ] fun in there so i think
in this big cage um
i think he's very very [ __ ] tough i
think i'm gonna be a lot faster than him
in in just
my goal is to go in there and make
someone look stupid make him not look
like they belong and they're with me
dude i love that [ __ ] yeah
that good that got me all nervous and
excited
[ __ ] dude i don't know what you're gonna
be there
dude i'm a [ __ ] fan bro dude thank
you brother i'm a fan bro you [ __ ]
yeah it always just like you know like
shooting text back and forth and like
[ __ ] instagram [ __ ] dude i get such a
kick out of it i'm like what was that
thing i sent you a message you
you're very consistent with your
meditation
me too i have to do it changed my life
yeah how often you do it every every
morning 10 minutes every single morning
and then like i do a hot tub cold plunge
every night so i get my cold punch it's
41 degrees i do it where in phoenix
where they make that
forge the guys coming to the show
tonight they wanted to
meet up today we should probably just go
run to an ice bath real quick it'll
[ __ ] make it i don't know i want to
get back to meditation though for you in
the morning i do it twice a day twice a
day i do it when i wake up
no matter what and then i do it
at some point before i go to bed yeah
dude i swear it's like it's such a
simple thing to do but it's so easy not
to do it well dude that's why i use that
little app because if i if heaven forbid
if i didn't do it for a day i would have
broken the streets yeah you're like
and and i'm so protective of you do you
do like 10 minutes in the morning five
minutes i i average 41 minutes total
every oh wow okay yeah it's like 20
minutes twice that's nice i i i
definitely could up mine and i showed up
mine i do 10 in the morning i have a
little princess now so it's like it's
it's it's definitely harder but i do
make sure i do it every morning i feel
like
um it's just makes me it sets you up for
a good day i believe it just plugs me
into the universe dude yeah i really
think like i got some crazy [ __ ]
beliefs about about meditation me too
yeah i preach it i always i always like
try to have a good message to people but
it's such a simple like i said simple
thing to do sit there observe your
thoughts or just observe your breath
whatever you want to do just 10 minutes
[ __ ] doing
something like that and it's powerful
dude it's so powerful
what's your take on doing like an uh
ice plunge every night i do it every
night three minutes 41 degrees it's
[ __ ] cold we gotta get one dude i
have a it's called plunge it's not even
a sponsor they did send me one but it's
like it's so it's so quality it's it's a
filtered i keep it on all the time 41
degrees get in there three minutes and
it's just like you have to sleep better
sleep so good dude but i get into my
breath i get into i get so [ __ ] high
off my breath like i'm sure tripping
sometimes like when i'm in there like
i'm like opening my eyes to make sure
i'm like am i still [ __ ] here but
it's the mixture between the ice and the
breathing is is magic i was trying to do
it every morning dude it's a game
changer oh it's magical
yeah
uh are you
you brought a filmer so you're putting
out like vlog videos type deal yeah we
we try to stay consistent on youtube in
camp like
outside of camp we were doing like one
every wednesday inside a camp it's like
i just
i don't do as much i'm like there's not
really as much to record like some
training sessions we record like i i
haven't done anything like came to
someone's podcast at all in camp so yeah
i might as well bring bring jay along
shoot some footage the elk boys are
actually coming into town tomorrow and
i'm going to be on their podcast which
will be [ __ ] cool
their last video they posted last night
was so [ __ ] funny dude it was saleem
and kyle and they pretended to be they
posted and said hey do any girls want to
pretend i'm their boyfriend and meet
their parents so they dress all hood
gangsta and then meet these girls
parents and it's the first time eating
the girls and it's so [ __ ] funny i
couldn't do it i couldn't hold that face
and like play along with that they're
good actors basically yeah that was
[ __ ] funny dude i was howling
nice dude what are you going to say
scott well it's not important anymore
it's not it's kind of weird now
we're going to say [ __ ]
hall ass to
sugarshow.com
someone already [ __ ] charged me the
letter yeah
sugarshow.comshop.com
yep bringing the same site and uh
and on instagram uh instagram's sean
o'malley ufc
pretty sure wait
no sugar shawn yes if you just type in
sean
i've been a message saying that i'm like
shadow man like you type in shaun
o'malley and they can't find me
because i post weed stuff i don't know
instagram is very strict so sometimes
it's hard to find find certain people
like it's it's a real like shadow band
stuff's a real issue like i guess
everyone said i'm shadow man but
sometimes i [ __ ] think i am because
some people have sent me like
screenshots like you don't pop up when
you type in sean o'malley but yeah i
think sugar shawn mma is actually my
instagram yeah all right well [ __ ] man
dad like i said man i'm a fan dude like
uh i'll be doing a show uh when when you
compete next but like as i do you know
what i'm [ __ ] trying i'm gonna knock
him out and you're gonna go what the
[ __ ] is that happening
backstage you get a boner maybe
[Music]
dude when i first got there i was
tripping
and i'm sitting there with my i've got
fight pass on my phone listening to the
comments right right right
yeah that [ __ ] was funny
and it's with like it comes with like a
[ __ ] two-minute delay so you'll
you'll like tape shawn's fight and we'll
watch it after the show probably or
something like when i'm doing a show
like then after i get done performing i
come back and then i [ __ ] watch me
yeah do you stay away from twitter and
[ __ ] oh my god dude
i will move instagram off my own page
just in case because sometimes you click
we were in cancun and i had a message
from sonny that was really funny and i
showed him on my watch he's like
you thought i was showing him the stats
of the fight
it's like he doesn't ruin it though if
you know the outcomes like i want to
watch it well the best part was when you
messaged dana white and you're like dude
if i went when they started the contract
with espn and i come back to the hotel
room after the show to watch the thing i
go i go to the espn plus on demand the
thumbnail for the [ __ ] event would be
the guy celebrating
inside message dana i'm like dude i'm
coming i'm coming to the [ __ ] page
because i
i wanna i want to watch it
and it's telling me where i head into
that so yeah dude so i got it fixed oh
no way they
he said i just screenshotted this and
sent it to the president of espn and the
number two at disney and it was fixed
that's sweet that's actually good that
was you probably saved a lot of people
from going far yeah for sure awesome man
well dude [ __ ] uh thank you for your
man thank you for having me
yeah right now that was fun [ __ ] yeah
i'm glad because i know we talked about
it last time in our pod you said next
time you come down we're doing the
partners it was pumped for us
yeah
so yeah dude [ __ ] hell yeah everybody
[ __ ] you
yeah dudes so let me tell you guys one
thing that means so much to me on this
tour i have met so many people who
identified themselves to me as being
part of the street team i know i haven't
said it in a while but dudes those of
you who watch the whole
podcast stick around to the very end you
do mean so much to me and how about all
the people who posted their [ __ ]
spotify thing
saying your number one podcast that you
listened to the most was stevo's wild
ride you've listened to 70 some episode
for a total of 5 000 minutes i think you
guys are hearing me say this i love you
thank you so much man i never knew
podcasting was going to work out so well
i honestly didn't think my life would
work out very well and here my life is
pretty awesome and i have you guys to
thank for that
so let's get on stage and kick some ass
and hopefully i see you on this bucket
list tour yeah dude